monsieur benillouche bonjour merci
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt france
alors le gouvernement israélien doit
donc détaillé aujourd'hui ce plan pour
le proche orient et notamment l'annexion
d'une partie de la cisjordanie on sait
que c'est un plan qui est controversée
qui n'est pas acceptée par l'autorité
palestinienne à votre avis benyamin
nétanyahou va t'il foncé ou plutôt
temporisé aujourd'hui mon avis va
temporiser d'ailleurs un de ses proches
révèle kim ministre vient d'annoncer que
effectivement il ne pouvait pas avancer
parce qu'il n'avait pas le feu vert
américain
il faut savoir que en fait il ya de
fortes pressions de la part américaine
parce que ils se lèvent donateurs ne
souhaite pas qu'il y ait une décision
unilatérale
pour l'instant les israéliens essaye de
trouver une solution a aura b je dirais
c'est à dire que ils ont envoyé un
émissaire c'est à dire le chef du mossad
auprès de dieu du roi d'arabie séoudite
pour le rassurer en lui disant ne vous
inquiétez pas nous n'allons pas du tout
avec ses la vallée du jourdain
nous allons simplement à l'excès deux ou
trois par deux ou trois implantations
qui se trouve à la limite de la zone de
la ville de pertes est tout près de
jérusalem on part entre autres de maalé
adoumim qui est à quelques kilomètres de
jérusalem et ariel qui est à quelques km
de la ligne verte
donc on pense aujourd'hui que il y a un
gros problème c'est que les américains
ne sont pas prêts à accepter toute
décision unilatérale il serait dès lors
pourquoi pourquoi parce qu'ils sont
empreintes de de faire un forcing
ils ont envoyé deux de deux grandes
personnalités en israël avis berkowitz
qui est le le bras droit du chambre de
train et jean-louis aussi l'ambassadeur
freeman qui ce qu'ils ont fait pression
auprès d'eux ganz
le ministre adjoint le bistrot 12h10 on
me disait la défense pour essayer de
de londres et qu'il y avait une
nécessité de changer d'opinion
et puis récemment brionne brian haw qui
est le représentant américain pour
l'iran c'est vrai après avoir fait une
tournée dans votre pénis dans lego dans
le golfe s'est présenté en israël et
pour essayer de faire comprendre qu'il y
avait un intérêt pour israël de trouver
une autre solution au fait les
américains ont fait une pression même
auprès des palestiniens parce qu'ils
auront fait comprendre que la politique
de la chaise vide n'était pas une bonne
politique jusqu'à présent personne parmi
les palestiniens ne voulait accepter de
discuter ou de s'asseoir à une table de
négociation
il semble que les américains aient
réussi à persuader le premier ministre
mohammed shtayyeh pour lui faire
comprendre qu'il l'avait intérêt à
intervenir de manière importante dans
ces négociations en fait lui lui qui
personnes très intéressées c'est un os
se dirait un haut fonctionnaire
palestinien
c'est un grand économiste est en fait il
ne cache pas du tout sa volonté de
remplacer mahmoud abbas à la présidence
ah non ils ont fait miroiter tout un tas
davantage
et comme mahmoud abbas pour l'instant on
ne voit pas beaucoup il est il est
presque confiné à cause du duc au vide
et bien c'est lui à l'heure actuelle qui
est pratiquement le maître d'oeuvre de
la politique palestinienne
c'est lui il ya tout il ya tout de même
une grande volonté de la part des états
unis et d'israël d'agrandir au maximum
le territoire israélien d'ailleurs c'est
ce que souhaite un petit peu donald
trump avec ce fameux plan pour le proche
orient qui prévoit juste une petite
partie pour pour la palestine est ce
qu'aujourd'hui on peut dire que
finalement
la fenêtre de tir de benyamin nétanyahou
est quand même limité dans le temps on
sait que les élections qui vont arriver
au cas si donald trump n'était pas réélu
on sait que c'est joe biden est plutôt
hostile justement à une annexion c'est
vrai que c'est pour ça que trump
absolument faire vite
à l'heure actuelle les laissons basso
sont catastrophiques autres on pense
qu'il est battu aujourd'hui et certaines
informations en israël prétendent que si
les sondages continuent ils risquent de
ne pas se présenter tout simplement
alors c'est pour ça qu'il fait un
forcing c'est pour ça qu'il a envoyé
tout un tas de ces hauts fonctionnaires
auprès d'israël parce qu'il a besoin qu
israël fasse un geste une victoire de
prades dans le processus de paix
remontrer sakho sa cote est donc c'est
pour ça qu'il fait tout pour essayer de
convaincre netanyahu qui n'est pas temps
aujourd'hui de faire une élection donc
l'annexion n'aura pas lieu
telle qu'on la concevait c'est à dire
une annexion au total de certaines zones
il va y avoir une annexion je dirais à
minima cette année certaines villes vont
être avec ses bons à avoir vont passer
sous sous juridiction israélienne
mais ça n'est pas le cas d'une annexion
une quand on parle d'élection on alex à
la fois une implantation est tout ce
qu'il ya autour
merci d'aviron merci beaucoup
jacques benillouche de nous avoir
éclairé sur ce sujet je rappelle que
vous êtes journaliste indépendant merci